[Music]
okay the afternoon session I think will
be a little more technical maybe than
the morning session I'm saying that's
good or bad I'm just pointing out we're
gonna try and give you a little some
amount of detail about version 11 from
the protocol one out can everybody hear
me
not very well okay my name is Bob
Schieffer I'm from the laboratory for
computer science I'll take this one
opportunity to say I'm not from Project
Athena
so saying X was designed at project
Athena is not a complete statement
version 10 I did most of the protocol
design version 11 there are lots of us
I'm not the sole person there are lots
of Dec people up there the fact that
there are deck people was not a
significant factor okay I put myself in
the watchdog position of saying we're
going to make sure that that that there
are no deck influences you know of
saying we want to make the protocol look
like our hardware or something like that
but the the subject never came up okay
it was not a problem that's not gonna
work there the latest version of the
protocol will be available around at on
or before January 23rd via anonymous FTP
to zap that file if you can't get it
that way you can send me mail there and
I will honor those as I can if you
absolutely can't get it by mail you can
try and call me but I hate paper
too fast for you a my phone number you
probably already have if you kept any of
the original announcements the date of
the current version of the this version
this version will be January you know
something okay and it will be called
something like nearly release meanings
we doubt it will change again everybody
got this
yes
a mic went on should have happened this
morning Gina I can talk okay important
things to keep in mind the protocol is
mechanism not policy very important it's
the way we get everybody to agree on
this is we push the religious wars up
higher okay
and you'll also see in the toolkit stuff
the same kind of thing mechanism not
policy at some point somebody's going to
start fighting wars but it's not gonna
be me which is the important thing the
other thing that's important is what
we're defining here is a core protocol
that's extensible okay core is in two
aspects one is that we don't think it
will ever change again okay there's not
gonna be a version 12 in the sense that
there's a switch from version 10 to
version 11 if there is a version 12 it
won't be me okay
the hope is that we have enough
agreement that this can last for a while
okay I'm gonna dive in I'm gonna assume
you basically understand version 10 and
I'm not gonna explain what a window
hierarchy is and you know what network
transparency is you know you better know
that or you're gonna miss some things
you won't miss lots of things but you'll
miss some things I'm just I'm gonna tell
you what's different what's new okay
resources an important thing that we get
right in version 11 that we did wrong in
version 10 was food allocates resource
IDs in tenet was done by the server and
11 it's done by the client so you avoid
a round trip the allocation will be
hidden by X live so you don't have to
worry about it in version 10 resources
always went away they're always tied to
the connection and they went away when
the connection went away now you can
specify that they survive the connection
close meaning that exit route when it
wants to allocate two colors for the
background tile and then exits your two
colors don't get freed on you and it
changes to random colors again so things
like that auto work of having long
another's resources independent of of
their Creator I'm gonna go fast okay I
got a lot of ground to cover
windows we've added support for multiple
screens so a server can support
many many screens there's no implied
geometry the assumption is that there's
still just one keyboard in one pointing
device and exactly how the pointing
device might move between screens is is
not something that's mandated by the
protocol you could decide to add an
extension to switch it between or have
it sort of warp as you move fast or slow
or whatever that's that's it's not
implied there's no geometry there's now
support for Windows of different depth
as opposed to having all windows be the
same depth so if you have a 24-bit frame
buffer you can say I might support
Windows of 1 4 8 12 24 bits important
things were there is the amount of data
you have to ship if you're really trying
to do a monochrome image on a 24-bit
display you don't really want to send
24-bit images across and there's a
better match with memory allocation for
for backing stores and those kinds of
things window classes they're still
input-output windows like there always
were the normal kinds of windows there
are now input only windows which replace
the transparent windows that were in
version 10 that differ the major
difference here is input only windows
you can't output to okay it's illegal
output to them and they have no
interaction with output windows okay
whereas transparent windows still active
this money clipping things and we'll see
later how clipping gets handled the
class mechanism is extensible so
extensions might want to come in and say
oh I have this random new kind of class
I don't know double buffered windows or
something and they need special
semantics for them and so you the kinds
of classes are extensible color I'm not
going to say almost anything about
because there's a follow-on talk that's
going to talk more about it there is no
longer a single color map there are now
any number of logical color maps that
some subset of which will map into
Hardware color maps and they're
associated with Windows so that you know
which one which ones are associated with
which color maps there are now this is a
little overkill whisper
many color map classes though in version
10 there was just pseudo color and now
there is pseudo color meaning
non-segmented color map there's gray
sale as a generate the generate case
there's direct color as a segmented
color map true color is no color map and
static color as a read-only color map as
well as monochrome okay so we support
all those kinds of classes and a server
can support multiple kinds of classes in
this in the same server right so you can
have direct color windows and pseudo
color windows and through their color
maps window reconfiguration it's been
cleaned up instead of having separate
move right move resize reese tac
operations there's a single operation
that allows you to do any combination of
those all atomically and you can also
change the border width which you
couldn't do in version 10 and this funny
restriction about whenever you do
something the window pops up to the top
is gone so you can combine these and say
it stays in the same place or it goes
the bottom or goes the top or
combinations exposures we've come down
offer hobbyhorse in some ways there is
now support for backing store so you can
request it your window have a backing
store meaning several will remain retain
the contents in some way and you won't
get exposure events as windows cover it
and uncover it specifying the backing
store you can specify really going on
top this is it me or is it you can
specify which which bit planes are
important for the backing store so again
if you decide you're gonna build a
24-bit window but you're really treating
as a monochrome window you can say i
only need this this bit plane reserved
safe for me please and and fill the
others with this constant value and and
say virtual memory allocation you can
also begin to play tricks now that you
have backing store you can say well i'm
going to create a fairly large window
with a backing store and then i'm gonna
create a smaller parent window okay and
since backing store is actually to the
whole window and not to what's visible
you can pan around without getting
exposure events so you can use this as a
kind of
mechanism or viewport we also support
save unders meaning I can say for this
window please save the contents of any
windows under me when I come up okay for
like pop-up menus another exposure
avoidance mechanism is the notion of
gravity you can say when my window gets
resized I would like this region of my
window the contents to be preserved
you know don't throw them away save them
for me and you can specify any of the
nine nine primary compass points for
saying the the bit contents ought to
remain with the same fixed offset from
that Compass Point regardless of how my
window gets resized okay or you can say
keep them static meaning their absolute
position on the screen doesn't change or
you can say forget them which is the way
it works in version 10 throw them away
and give me an exposure event similarly
there's kind of there's a similar
mechanism for your children so you can
say how they should move when you get
resized and again you can give the same
Compass Point so you can say absolute on
the screen or you can say forget them
meaning unmapped them whenever I get
resized and then I'll take care of
resizing them and moving them and then
mapping them again and you get rid of
this funny effect that you often see in
current version 10 things have you
resized and it got so it's got 50 sub
windows at and they all flash around and
then they come in and then they settle
so both of those should be useful
mechanisms events multiple clients can
now select for events on the same window
and when they do the event gets
broadcast to all of them event
propagation now only applies to device
events not to all events and there's a
mask in each window that says which
device events should not propagate up
the tree so if you want to protect your
superiors from knowledge you can you can
you can turn off device propagation so
you can say I I'm not interested in this
event but my parents shouldn't be
interested in it either there are a
couple of new classes of events of
interest too
various kinds of applications their
structure notify which says I want to
know via an event anytime I get
reconfigured in any way if I get moved
if I get unmapped if I get mapped if I
get destroyed resized all those things
you can get notified about a number of
those you couldn't find out about in
version 10 for example being moved if
you want to protect yourself in some
ways between if you want to get an
adversary relationship with your window
manager you can say if if somebody other
than me tries to resize me don't let it
happen send me an event instead and I'll
take care of it I'll be I'll be
responsible citizen and and I may
twiddle it a little bit but I'll resize
myself you know the way you asked again
this has to do with Windows that have
lots of say sub windows or contents that
they want to somehow manage before they
get resized rather than after they get
resized you can also find out about
changes in visibility so now you can
find out when your window becomes
partially obscured or fully obscured or
completely unobscured so if you want to
for example decide to stop output or
input or something based on that you can
do it there a number of hooks for window
managers and we spent a lot of time
trying to figure out how to support all
the kinds of window managers that people
wanted to build but at least the ones
that people talk to us about that
wanting to build an important thing for
tiling window managers is both is one
being able to notice changes in
configuration of sub-windows so a window
manager might select on the route window
saying tell me anytime any first level
child changes okay like a new child gets
created or an existing child gets
destroyed okay some kinds of window
managers will want that information to
keep track of it rather than having to
continuously poll or or reget the state
every time they want to do something
they can keep a consistent state of what
the top level structure of the screen is
they can also do a a redirection similar
to what a client can do for resaw
saying for most kinds of configuration
if any child tries to reconfigure itself
don't let them do it send me an event
instead and I'll decide whether it's
proper and right for them to do it there
are certain things that can't be
redirected in particular creation
unmapped and destroy those are things
that the client can do at any time but
you can redirect things like move and
resize and map which are key things that
a tiling window manager needs to have
control over however when you get to
pop-up menus you want the pop-up menu to
say I don't care what kind of window
manager is running I don't want this
many to be tile way over there arbitrary
size right so there's an attribute on
the window called override redirect
which says forget what the window
manager wants you know I I know I'm
playing fair you know do what I you know
do what I mean ok
there's also now you can alter the
hierarchy you can you can repair it to
win you can say pick up this hierarchy
and this this sub piece of the hierarchy
move it over there this has for example
a window manager that wants to provide
uniform title bars or complex border
decorations around any window can simply
create a new window and then reparent
the old one inside of it and then draw
the title bars and border declarations
in that parent new parent window and
this is completely invisible to the
application there are a number of
version 10 hooks for things like the
window name and the icon and what the
resize hint to the window manager ought
to be all those things have been flushed
in favor of a general property list
mechanism where you can say I have this
piece of data and I want to call it this
name and attach it to this window and
you can have an agreement but among
window managers for example that says
the property named name should have an
interpretation on the data of being you
know ASCII and you can do similar kinds
of things so there's a general mechanism
there to allow window managers to
communicate with each other and in a
subsequent talk there'll be more
discussion about how it can be used
between clients as well and there's an
event associated with that so you can
tell when properties on a window get
changed
your client communication is what will
be in the next talk talking about
properties being able to send events the
notion of selections and and the one
thing I want to point out is that cut
buffers as in version 10 have been gone
because they're subsumed by the other
mechanisms building on the pointer once
called a mouse now called a pointer
because it's not necessarily a mouse no
longer just three buttons you can have
any number of buttons at most five of
which are reported in device events so
you can only have instantaneous State on
five but otherwise you can interact with
any number of them you get events for
all of them and you can grab them and so
on in the area of motion events you can
now say I only want motion events as a
hint meaning only send me one and then
don't send me any more until I query
what the what the pointer position is
and this sort of corresponds directly to
what lots of version 10 applications
were doing when they were tracking the
mouse which was exactly that using the
motion event as a hint to wake up and
then they would just go pull the mouse
and discard any motion events that had
come in between so now you can do that
and save the server the pain and
suffering of having to shove all those
events across the network the server has
always been free to discard motion
events and compact them in as it sees
these soft fit there is now a request
that allows you to get more detailed
motion information about a window so the
server may maintain some amount of past
history about very fine grained motion
of the mouse and you can say between
this time and this time tell me all the
mouse motion events related to this
window and what the coordinates in this
window were so draw programs although
perhaps not as real-time at least can
get the information the keyboard the
number of modifiers has gone up from
whatever it was four to eight only three
of which now have standard definitions
shift caps lock and control and the
other five can be mapped to whatever you
like them whatever you want them to be
whatever modifiers you happen to have on
your particular keyboard you can now
query
for the instantaneous state of the
keyboard to figure out what all keys are
up and what all keys are down and
associated with that is the ability to
ask for a new kind of event on the
window saying anytime the pointer enters
my window or any time the focus comes to
my window
send me the key map state at that point
so I applications that want to use
non-standard modifiers or want to do
courting applications won't have any
race conditions they'll know at that
point before any real input happens what
the full state of the keyboard is better
talk fast device mappings you can now
inside the server change what the
physical to logical mapping of buttons
and keys is and this then applies to all
clients rather than just the one who was
using this key map file to change it
locally the advantage of that is that
now when you remap things like I want
this to be the shift key or something it
will actually work right with respect to
grabs and other things in the server so
in most cases traditional use of X key
map of saying I want the greater than
key there on my LK 201 should go away in
grabs grabs have been extended so you
can not only grab buttons and the
pointer but you can now also grab keys
in the keyboard for pointer grabs there
is now confined to window meaning when
the graph activates make sure warp the
pointer inside the window if necessary
and don't allow it to escape that window
until the grab deactivates the
restriction on the hierarchy of saying
only within any ancestor chain only one
grab on a given button can be
outstanding has gone away into a
hierarchy so that the way event
processing work is grabs go first from
root down and then window interest goes
second from bottom up okay and it if you
think about it long enough you decide
it's the right thing so a window manager
might for example and we'll get to this
I get an example right here so we'll
come to it associated with grabs now is
the ability to freeze
the processing of device events so you
can do synchronization and avoid race
conditions and I'll give an example
once you've frozen a device the kinds of
thaw modes are make it asynchronous
again just let it go send one more event
and then freeze again or replay the last
event and avoid the fact that I had
grabbed it originally okay now an
example of that is let's say you've got
a manager that wants to take the first
click on a window and use it to set the
focus to that window okay well what you
would do is grab the button on that
window and say I want the pointer to
freeze when it happens okay at the down
event you'll get the down event and the
pointer will are frozen at that point
you can change the focus and then you
have a choice if you want the
application to not see the click then
you can just saw the device in
asynchronous mode and then you'll get
the up event and and and as part of the
grab and then things will go along
Jolley if you actually want to click to
also go to the application then you can
simply replay the event meaning send the
event process the event again ok but
ignore the fact that I have a grabbed ok
now the application controlling that
window may also have that button grabbed
and in that case it's grab will activate
next okay and there may be a hierarchy
of things going down through that which
may happen if you sort of have managers
within managers for example in a tool
kit layer it's conceivable that you may
want the same kind of management within
a window that you know a top-level
manager wants to have I'll screen images
picks Maps you can now have all scream
engines of multiple depths the server
can support various kinds of depths they
can now be drawn into with all the
normal graphics operations bitmaps have
gone away they're just pix maps and they
have various depths we have a new this
new notion called a drawable which is
either pixmap or an input-output window
graphics have changed from being
stateless to being state based so
there's a new resource called a graphics
context it's not part of the drawable
when you issue a Request you get both
the graphics context and a drawable and
we'll explain more about what a drawable
is once you have a graphics context it
can be used with any drawable of the
same depth on the same screen so when
you create a graphics context you say
what kind of depth window what kind of
depth drawable you want and what screen
is for having state based graphics
allows faster server implementations
because they're a better match with many
kinds of hardware now coming out or
already existing also having state-based
minimizes bandwidth because there are
now all these gazillions of options as
you'll see that you don't have to pass
every time you just pass this resource
identifier for having a graphics context
also allows transparent extensions
without applications necessarily having
to notice the change everywhere and
making you compatible changes so for
example if you want to add a coordinate
transform which as you'll see doesn't
exist in the core graphics context you
can simply add a add an extension
request that says please please add a
coordinate transform to this GC and then
all your standard graphics operations
will continue to function without having
an extra argument one thing to note in
terms of graphics context is one should
assume as its traditional in operating
systems that context switches are
expensive ok the idea is these are still
mapping into hardware States and anytime
you have to switch Hardware States
you're going to have more logical things
than physical things ok and something
you're gonna have to do this complex
check to see what's changed and update
all the CSRs and all that magic so
assuming that graphics contexts are free
is not the right thing kinds of graphics
you can draw points you can draw lines
all of these things are now poly
requests meanings that you can give this
arbitrary length list of them in a
single request rather than having just
line or point ok you can give a list of
points list of lines a list of polyline
means you give each successive vertex
and it draws continuously poly segments
means I'm just giving you individual
line segments to draw rectangles fill
rectangles arts given by a bounding box
to start angle and an extent a goal
filled arcs filled polygons and text and
I'll get back to text what happened to X
draw X draw has disappeared from the
protocol and will be provided as an X
live routine on the application side to
do the complex D transfer transformation
when you think you need it
lines have PostScript style semantics so
the brush state the calligraphy in
version 10 went away in favor of realign
with there is cap style with for the end
points but round projecting and for
those who like still like to think in
terms of not drawing the last point for
for a single pixel lines there's only
not last mode there's a joint style
meaning that when for example you're
doing a polyline for wide lines you want
to know whether the joins should be how
they should look and you can specify
mitered round and beveled and for line
Styles there are solid lines meaning a
single color actually that's not quite
true we'll say and dashes both on off
and and double dashes alternating colors
and there's also just like in PostScript
a general - array instead of this funny
thing that was in version 10 and a pixel
offset into the - array for telling how
to how to start the dashes filling the
kinds of things you can the ways in
which you can fill you can fill with a
solid pixel you can fill with the tile
and you can stipple with a pixel you can
now alter the stipple tile origin
without having to reconstruct you know
rotate the tile in funny ways filling
applies uniformly to all graphics okay
including lines when you draw a wide
line you think of that as filling a
polygon okay
and filling applies to it same with text
Texas view - stippling so you can have
tiled and you know funny text for
polygons we support both the even on and
the non zero whining rules and if you
don't know what they are then you
probably don't care
and for an arc you can fill either as a
pie slice or you can fill according to
the cord joining joining of two end
points for clipping you can now
explicitly give an additional mask for
clipping and that can be specified
either as a list of rectangles or as a
bitmap and of course you can if somebody
wants you know trapezoids or something
they can add an extension request to to
specify you know the the input side of
what that looks like and the server can
transform it to whatever it wants
internally given a clipping mask you can
change the origin of it move it around
within the drawable without having to
ship the whole thing again so summary of
what a graphics context contains and
this is why you don't want to use pests
in every request it's got the logic
function in the plane mask just like in
version 10 foreground and background
pixels the tile and the stipple and the
origin for them the line with cap style
join style - style pattern offset all
these things okay in the font it also
includes the sub window mode so that you
can say when I'm drawing to a window
whether to clip according to the
children or actually draw through the
children and for things like bit blit
whether bit blit should generate
exposure events is now an attribute of
the graphics contracts rather than an
attribute of the window bit blit copy
area has been generalized so you can now
do it between drawables rather than just
within a drawable they have to be the
same depth and have to be on the same
screen and there's now copy plane which
allows you to copy a single bit plane
instead of all the bit planes and that
can be done across drawables of
different depths but still on the same
screen the image is the image ordering
in terms of bit order byte order and
padding requirements are now controlled
by the server and not by the protocol
okay this means that on the XY client
side you have this slightly hairy
problem of converting from one format to
the other of course you always had that
but now it's sort of N squared or
something depending on what you think
you want to use internally but X Y was
going to support that kind of thing the
important thing is now you can actually
generally do that on the fly as you
transmitted rather than having the
server get the whole thing in place and
then have to do this in place swap which
can be very expensive when retrieving an
image back out you can now just get a
subset of the planes instead of always
getting all of the planes so if you
really know I only have this monochrome
image and it happens to be a 24-bit
display you don't have to get three
megabytes of data back fonts fonts are
finally the right thing I think you can
draw in all of the four major directions
left-to-right right-to-left
bottom-up top-down we now fonts have all
have kerning information there's support
for large glyph sets like Japanese
fonts have a property list a numeric
property list rather than general data
property lists but it's very similar to
the popular song windows where you can
specify additional optional information
like what the spacing should be the
italic angle the point size the 37
properties that tech defines for
mathematics fonts you know whatever you
like you can now ask the server to give
you all the font names that match a
given pattern and also to retrieve those
properties without actually creating
them as resources and querying them to
allow you to do reasonable font
selection and you can also set the font
search path and I'm close to done text
related to fonts okay so when you do
text you now have both 8 and 16-bit
characters you can't mix in a request
you either use text or 16-bit text
within a given text operon text request
you can do both motion along the
baseline
and you can do font shifts okay so you
can basically in general do a whole line
of text in a single request the the care
pad and space pad randomness in version
10 is gone in favor of general motion
along the line and last extensions the
idea is this is a core protocol but it
can be extended in lots and lots of ways
that I'm sure we haven't possibly
thought of yet the idea for an extension
is very simple you say server do you
have loaded extension mumble okay
mumble is just this random string and
the server comes back and tells you yes
or no basically and if it tells you yes
then what it tells you is the base
opcode for requests is here and it's
assumed to be contiguous after that all
the op codes assigned to that extension
and you get back if it wants to extend
the events kinds of events you get back
the base event code forward if it wants
additional errors you give to back the
base error code the important thing
about all of these is that they're
dynamically assigned the client doesn't
know what they are until it queries and
gets them back okay so the idea is a
client is not bound to any given
implementation as long as the extension
exists in all the servers it should be
able to determine dynamically what based
what what you know constant to add to
all the op codes and so on to get the
right thing to happen the assumption is
that an extension typically will have a
single major opcode and then lots of
minor op codes inside of it whose format
we don't say anything about but that's
the idea is that extension should be
fairly large grain things like 3d
graphics which is an example that you
hear about this afternoon and that's all
I wanted to say so questions
do I have these summaries printed I
don't I mean I would say you know if
what you want to do is get the protocol
document because you may say that's too
much I don't want to read 50 pages if
you if you send me mail I can send you
you know the text source to this if that
will do you any good as I say I hate
paper and I haven't actually reproduced
it summary of protocol changes is that
the thing you wrote okay it hasn't been
updated maybe we'll get around to that
are there any performance comparisons
this is a protocol you when when the
server implementation talk comes up you
can ask them that and I won't tell you
what the answer is because they probably
don't know
there there there are two possibilities
actually there are more than two I mean
one possibility is to say if you want
those you convert them in to polylines
before you ship them and whether that's
expensive depends on how often you're
doing it and how you know how many Polly
you know how big the polyline resulting
you actually think is going to happen
the alternative is if enough people
think those kinds of curds are important
you can always define an extension that
will do that transformation to a
polyline which is probably what you're
gonna end up doing ultimately okay and
do it in the server side so it's really
only a question of bandwidth okay and
and whether bandwidth is important is is
gonna depend on a lot of factors sure
well depends only do you think you have
shared libraries or not right
see I'm not I I don't think Unix anymore
so
the question is right the question is we
haven't seen any detailed semantics
about what line width and so on means my
belief is that the spec that we will see
on January 23rd is fairly precise about
what all that means and if it isn't send
me mail call me up one or two more
it is still basically aligned on 32-bit
boundaries know that you'll be the last
well there are any extensions that have
already been defined there are a number
of extensions that are in progress over
which I have no control and you'll hear
about one of them today I'm sure that
there are others I'm no longer in a
position I mean you have to realize now
you know the cat is long out of the bag
okay
MIT is no longer a focal point for
what's going on in in vendor world
okay so god only knows what they're
doing there is no constant there is no
concept of a reserved extension exactly
I mean an important if you if you if you
start to look at the verbiage of the
press conference today okay the idea is
look guys okay we've got it we've got
ourselves a toehold now but there are
all these higher levels that we still
have to standardize on and they're all
these things that the core protocol
doesn't talk about that we still have to
standardize on and you know one of the
things we'll be talking about at the
Boff on the protocol tomorrow is you
know beginnings of how do we you know
how do we start to tackle that problem
you know what kind of standards
committee or whatever do we do for
saying I got this wonderful extension I
want every to everybody to buy into it
and and consider it part of the core
that everyone should have some exists I
think I'm going to defer more questions
and there'll be Q&A at the end of the
day and people can ask more questions
[Applause]
I'm Phil Carlton and for predictably
assisting ssin of being the only person
that was on the protocol design group to
also be implementing the server talk a
little bit today about some of the
mechanisms that were they were put into
x11 to support inter client
communication know as Bob talked about
before this is all policy free I'll tell
you what the mechanisms do and for a
couple of things I'll give you examples
of how they might be used this is not to
say that they're limited in any way to
be used that way but I'll show you what
we got Bob mentioned Adams they're
basically just strings you pass them in
and we didn't want to have to pass in
long ASCII strings all the time we did
things expensive to compare and so the
server will map strings to unique IDs
and you get the string name back if you
care and every time you give the same
string you get the same unique ID and
that's convenient this server has no
semantic values for any of the any of
the atom names whatsoever
they're totally up to the clients to
agree upon what they're going to do with
that atoms we using various ways in the
in the server one of them is for naming
properties properties just a bunch of
bunch of bytes and you stick it on a
window and and there it is it's got a
type it's also named by an atom and so
you can stick properties on your window
or somebody else's window and now you do
some mechanism to let them know that
that that that atom exists and so what
you can do is you can send an event and
just like there all the all the events
the extension events in the core events
that can get sent from the server to any
any window any client you can any client
can send any event to some other other
client the server flips a bit on in the
event let the I think receiving client
know that this was not necessarily
generated by the server maybe they want
to watch out your choice there's one
event that's never generated by the
server and it's uh
squilliam is interpret notify and this
mechanisms allows you to send an event
to a particular particular client to any
client any window and you can tell us
some information like where is intended
you do is you stick a property over in
some window under some name and you send
an event to the to the other client to
the window and when he gets it he gets
us interpret notify event and inside
that says where did you put the property
cuz he probably will get the value
because that's what you're trying to
send to him you tell them what the name
of the property is so you can also find
that you tell them what you want to do
it do with it for instance if you stuck
a property onto somebody else's window
and sent him an event that said please
insert this text at this property that
you'll find your current input focus or
your current insertion point it could do
that now the super to reiterate the
semantics of those atoms are totally up
to the clients to agree upon it's not
the business of the server to be doing
that so say something else but I forgot
one more mechanism that was added it's
the notion of the other selection there
are some user interfaces and not all
that rely real heavily on the notion of
a current selection and so there's some
support support for that in the protocol
and the user thinks he owns the
selection because he can see it
highlighted on the screen and those
kinds of user interfaces actually in the
in the new protocol the selection is
owned by any particular window and any
window at any time can come along and
say I would like to be the owner of the
selection and then the server is nice
enough to tell the old previous owner
you're no longer the owner please D
highlight your selection or whatever
your semantics aren't go ahead and do
that and and then the original
application call I goes over and
highlights the new selection the reason
the word here's it's not actually
exactly one selection there are some
user interfaces have the notion of a
primary in a secondary selection and we
don't know then probably somebody out
there with a tertiary and so on
selections and so selections are named
by Adams so you want to become the owner
of the primary selection and it's up to
you to choose the name it's probably
gonna be primary so you say I would like
to be do under the primary selection
your hand in a window handle and you're
the owner
notice no bytes were transferred the
value of the selection is not
transferred or anything like that
somehow the owner of the selection is
gonna be told later that somebody else
wants the value and that gets done by a
convert selection call
[Applause]
what happens is that the some client
sends a request to the server saying
please convert the selection of the
primary selection for instance a text or
to a circle or a busy a curve or
whatever it wants and we don't know and
what happens is that the server
remembers who the owner of the current
selection is and says them a particular
event called selection request and the
owner the selection takes that and it
figures out who it came from and it's
got all that information and the
intention is what it does is goes off to
the guy who we put the requesters window
sticks a property on it and sends that
an event to that guy saying the event
the data you asked for is there if the
owner of the selection is unable to
convert it for instance you ask somebody
to convert the selection and happens to
be the characters the2 a circle it might
just say sorry I couldn't do that and
send an event saying I couldn't do it
you can almost think of this as a as a
request to the owner of the selection to
send you and interpret notify and their
few other folks saying how you want to
get it and what your why you want this
thing and I thought I'd go through a
very very brief example of how the
selection mechanism might be used oh I
remember what I was gonna say about
interpret notify you've probably all
noticed that you could implement any
kind of communications protocol you
wanted to on top of that it was not the
intention by any of the designers or the
implementers of the server that that'd
be efficient or a wonderful thing to do
in other words go talk to the other
client when you find out his name and
and set up your own connection here's
the example I'm gonna posit that we have
running on some server we have an editor
running on some machine and you're
viewing some source code one of the
favorite things that programmers like to
do and it's some other window we have a
debugger running and the editor and the
debugger I don't know anything about
each other but they've agreed upon some
semantics were first particular atoms
and so the user sitting there and he's
looking at the source code he's got some
line the question he doesn't quite
understand he selects the characters and
the line somehow it goes over to the
debugger window and he hits the set
breakpoint button follow the debugger
doesn't know what to do so it sends out
a request to the corner of the current
select and says please tell me the
filename that's currently being viewed
by the in the window that owns the
current selection and he gets back the
answer well it's the famous X clock
program
and then he sends another request to him
and says hey tell me what character
position you are in the in the file he
gets back well this 512 it looks in his
fine-grained table and says what will be
line 36 and it goes off and it sets a
breakpoint and it's done and notice that
the owner of the selection and the
requester didn't know anything about
each other not necessarily in the same
operating system and they basically
don't care but they're still able to do
the inter client communication using
that mechanism that's it questions
[Applause]